um
ugh
hello everyone and welcome to another
day of games play for all
charity streams we have a very very
exciting day today
uh joining me and tam to play some
resident evil village
you might recognize him it's mike
mccarty and
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we gave the overlay out it's uh it's not
our fault um
but we're also joined by very very
special guest maggie robertson
aka the voice and performance actor for
lady dimitressk welcome thank you so
much for joining us today
hey thank you so much for having me i'm
so excited to be here
i can't um so today we're going to be
playing some resident evil village
mary you are in the driver's seat do you
want to tell us what we're going to be
doing today
yeah we are in the house
dibatrisk i thought it would be really
fun
to run around uh from the lady
where is she oh my god i hear stressful
noises but i don't know where she is
but you are here so i'm so excited to
talk to you a little bit
about like your motivations of this
character and how you made her so
so terrifying but also so alluring no
place left to run oh [ __ ]
she's actually yeah
i guess i guess the first question is
i'm sure you've been asked this one
million times but
are you surprised at like putting so
much effort into making this menacing
threat and then everyone just falling in
love with her and being like yes please
chase me
it is kind of ironic isn't it um
everything about the reaction to this
character into this game has been a
surprise to me
i this is kind of my big breakout moment
i've never done performance capture
before so literally everything is new
and i went into this with no
expectations on the outcome i was just
happy to have a job and be working with
amazing people and then
all of this happened and every day i'm
like what
every day there's something new that
blows my mind
so yes we should also say uh up front
i'm just about to tweet this out too but
maggie very kindly provided a a signed
poster
of the resident evil village cast uh
here it is on display
um if you donate ten dollars
at the link on screen right now it's in
the description
tinyurl.complayforall2021 if you donate
ten dollars
and then reply to my tweet that's gonna
go out in one second
um with a screenshot of your donation
make sure to blur out
any key information uh don't dox
yourself
uh i will you know we were gonna put all
of the names of folks who've donated 10
or more into a raffle and at the end of
the stream we will use a random selector
to pick uh a winner so please enter
uh and we'll donate and then answer
you'll make the best vintage
do it it's a poster you get signatures
for the
price of one oh my god look at her
she's just i think you have all three
masks in which case you could go
to i mean it might be spoilery but it
would be a fun thing to watch
when lady d kind of uh becomes something
else so to speak
right is that right after this or is it
later
i guess that's my other pretty soon
after you put all the masks in okay i
have all the masks which unfortunately
makes us miss the
um this was the latest save i had oh
you're so big i can kite her um she
she's so scary that's right uh i have
all the masks so i'm gonna miss the
phone ringing scene which was one of my
favorites i wanted to talk to you
about that scene um they used it
in a lot of the advertising for this
game to show how
uh how double-sided she is very proper
very um brought up
seems like she has a lot of manners
and angry how did you kind of
be able to handle two sides of this of
this character
so every time she speaks i'm it's so
hard to focus when you're also
watching and anyway yes um yes
i think that's one of the coolest things
about her is that she does have that
duality these
conflicting um parts of her personality
and that i think is part of why she's
such a magnetic and
um spellbinding character so
i think for me what i was thinking about
is on the outside her exterior is
presenting a very composed graceful
regal front she's very controlled in her
movement qualities and she plays very
high status
and then underneath of that i think that
rage and that aggression comes out
because she is
in fact a deeply emotional person
she got you um she's a very emotional
person she cares very deeply
and it was so fun to play with those
two extremes and those two dualities to
her
is there a death animation for her uh
for uh me
when she gets you started uh
i think so i just can't help myself
what's it like to hear you how much
creepy laughter
because so many sessions of me just
cackling magically
what is it like for you to hear your
voice and also hear it coming out of a
character that is you know
like that oh it's weird it's totally
bizarre but i think actually the fact
that she doesn't look like me
helps me maintain a level of distance
and detachment so that i can watch it
more objectively and
interact with the game more as a fan
rather than if it was on camera i'd be
sitting there thinking about all the
moments i could have done better um
no place left to run
i'm not gonna make it open
open up oh shoot i want these
because she come in here okay good i
don't think she does i think she's
caught by that door [ __ ] too tall
hey so small oh that's so ominous
that just over the shoulder it's the
over-the-shoulder look that i'm always
like i know you know
i know i love that move in the trailer
the iconic when she
looks around and then turns after they
string her up that is the epitome of
lady dee to me
both charming sensual but also
terrifying
yeah it's just i mean like she's such a
unique
uh i mean like mike you can speak to
this right like there's truly
no other character like her in all of
resident evil right
she's like the closest you get is ada
and like ayden's not a
a monster of any kind um like
every all the others are kind
yeah there's a villain in resident five
that's i feel like they went for a
similar vein but didn't execute it
nearly as well i think she was
too over the top in a way that lady d
still has this groundedness to her
because she's like this
she still plays it's funny seeing her in
the family dynamic with like heisenberg
and morrow and everybody because she
plays this kind of domineering older
sister that
wants very much to be the matriarch of
the family even though lady miranda is
the powerful one it's funny seeing her
in that family dynamic with them
yeah how did you family dynamics are
scary
how did you get that like were you were
you in the same room as the other
uh performance eyes or was it like a
remotely
turn the game played down a little bit
just for the shrieks you guys don't you
guys don't like hearing
her scream at you it's popping off man
i turned it down about 10 db um you know
you said you don't feel like you
identify
as her visually you don't look like this
[Music]
you know it's so weird right ah where do
i go
i didn't think this through okay
um
let me get your question yes go ahead
i know who wouldn't be um but yeah no we
filmed that first
opening scene in that church place we
did that all together in
in the volume and so it was really cool
to have everyone there in the space and
then you could really investigate these
family dynamics and
as an actor there's so much information
about the characters that you don't have
like a lot of her backstory i didn't
know about her
blood disease when we were filming this
for instance but
the only things i really needed to know
were the relationships how did she
feel about this person or that person
and that was what i mostly used to base
all of my acting choices off of
um it was cool to have everyone in the
same place
and to play off of each other that was
cool except that we couldn't look each
other in the eyes because i'm so tall
so that was interesting and on camera
typically you are able to like have a
dialogue with someone
there was a little yeah essentially yeah
there was a little cue for eye lines and
everyone else had to look above my head
and i was kind of looking at people in
hip knee height area so we're having
these exchanges
but no eye contact is happening
i guess that's that's yeah because like
you're
you're still pretending to look down i
guess
where you're where they are supposed to
be relative to you so that must be
so cool exactly yeah it was very strange
we've got a bunch of donations that i
want to read through we've got james
cole who gave twenty dollars
james anonymous gave fifteen dollars
julian uh space gave twenty dollars
the moulin rouge gave ten dollars and
said super great cause with a great cast
rain nine six one five gave uh fifteen
dollars
matt hawking gave ten dollars just
booked traffic
gave ten dollars elizabeth mueller ten
dollars there was also
uh kanini for life and said
uh y'all seriously rock uh being great
people
amazing kanini is life thank you so much
for all those amazing donations oh my
god
it's so hard to keep composure under
these conditions
mary you're doing so well like this is
uh this is the point when i was playing
and my roommate came in because i'd been
i'm i'm
terrible with like scary games and i had
been okay
up until this bit where she just keeps
coming round and i just felt
really i felt more claustrophobic here
on this rooftop than i think i did
walking around the halls
of the house breaking every pot that i
saw i'm very sorry
it was like a must to a flame every pot
i saw
i smashed it just ruining my beautiful
homes
what upset you more us murdering your
children or your pots in your beautiful
house
um i have to say my children
fair enough that's our close second
maggie what was the direction like for
this part did they tell you like okay
now you're a fleshy giant gargoyle
i can't imagine what they told you to
voice this part
yeah i did they give you a visual i knew
what she was going to turn into
i had visuals and i knew what she was
going to turn into and then we just kind
of played around
with how bestial i could get my voice to
go and
um just going crazy those sessions were
insane and there was definitely moments
where
i'd do make some noise and go crazy or
do some maniacal cackle and i'd look
over and steve knibley our director
would just be shaking his head laughing
at me and
i think that was surreal because i would
do that and i'd be like this is my job i
get to come to work and do
this and make weird noises all day long
it was
amazing i think for me the best resident
evil
boss fights are the ones that like make
you abandon
any attempt at conserving ammo like this
you spend so long being like i'm gonna
be very careful with ammo
but then you inevitably there's one
fight that ratchets the tension where
you're like i don't care about ammo i
just need to get this thing out of here
and this is definitely one of those
fights i was unloading everything i had
i was like just please get away from me
i love that she's terrifying she is yeah
it even freaks me out i'm like oh my god
i did that with my voice jesus
yeah they did some uh a little bit of
effecting to
make her sound i think more i don't know
echoey but
this is your fairies you you sound
so scary in this and you've done a
tremendous job
really conveying just how how
scary she is for sure
yeah got you is where she finally gets
to let loose
she's abandoned the graceful put
together exterior and now she's just
getting full into rage
bugs i don't think there's been
a resident evil character or villain
like post so like we have a lot of
resident evil characters recently that
have like not risen to prominence but
kind of like step back into the
spotlight with like
you know the uh the tyrant and nemesis
and that kind of stuff but it's been
ages since we had like a brand new
like heavy hitting contender that lady d
is definitely
going to go down in history as one of
the coolest resident evil villains she's
absolutely in the history books as the
tallest which is really cool
yeah yeah definitely yeah i mean just
i'm keeping an eye on our youtube chat
here and i
like i think mr x everyone had like the
memes and stuff but i have never seen
such
love for a character like
the youtube chat here is just like uh
maggie you are the true queen of this
game
i love you lady d i will die for lady d
oh my god i think and obviously
i want lady d to step on me which i
think obviously
you've had a lot um what's it like to
have that fan reaction like even before
the game came out everyone immediately
just went
who is she yeah that was hilarious
i'm sorry my phantom ghost light over
here is bugging out but anyway
um that was hilarious because i was
still under nda so i wasn't able to say
anything so i was just being creepy on
the internet
looking at everything and not saying
anything and i remember there were even
some reddit threads that i went through
and
people were like trying to guess who the
voice actress was and guessing
incorrectly and then once my name was
finally released they were like
who is this and why have we never heard
of her before i must know
everything it's it's very surreal it's
mind-blowing to me that people want to
know what i have to say you know what i
mean like i wasn't i was invisible and i
was anonymous before this moment and now
all of a sudden i'm very much not that
anymore
it's very um humbling and
i feel quite honored to have gotten the
response that i've gotten from fans and
it's it's surreal i keep going back to
it's surreal it's wild it's bonkers it's
crazy because
it is all of those things have you been
keeping tonight have you been keep an
eye on the fan art because the fan art
is
absurd some of it is so good
i love it people are really letting
their creativity shine and there's so
much talent out there
you guys come to me and you're like oh
my god maggie you're so talented and
then i look at your fan art and i'm like
oh my god you're so talented like what
um it's crazy i love it yeah and i love
it too because
she kind of the way i see lady d is now
that the game's released
she is separate from me and she has kind
of taken on this life of her own
and the fan art does so much to add to
the character and build on this world
and so i just feel like she's really
um coming into her own and
[Applause]
yeah there's a there's this amazing i
don't know if it's a model if it's just
fan art but someone's gone back to like
one of my favorite games of all time
marvel vs capcom
which is a massive like fighting game
and put lady dimitrescu
in there and like she's she's like
beating up gambit and members of the
x-men
and like crying onslaught like toe to
toe and it's like
so good yes oh that's awesome i'm gonna
have to look for that
that's so good
oh wait clam do you want to hit the
donations again we're getting quite a
few
and i've got like a bunch of people who
are replying to the tweet with their
donations i'm going to make
well i'm a producer so i'm going to do
what i do best to make a spreadsheet
so we have tyler rodriguez who gave 20
dollars and said glad to be
glad to help out anyone who likes gaming
also
thank you for bringing on uh woman of
the year maggie robertson
woman of the year uh emily 10
tom ten dollars he said this is a really
great cause
um raven gave fifteen dollars
uh aliyah lovin gave ten dollars
uh angelique thirty five dollars
anonymous twenty dollars
emily ten dollars and leo ten dollars
emily said
uh lady d is perfect which amazing cause
maggie is the perfect lady d
um leo who said great glory to house
demetrisk
glory to house wow that is well
uh remember if you want the chance of
winning the signed resident evil village
cast poster uh reply to my tweet i'm at
lucy james games i will pin it
um it's the top one on my page reply
with your uh your tiltify sort of
donation but blur out your
your identifying info i just need you
tweet and if you win we'll put you into
a random
uh generator and if you win i will uh dm
you and we'll arrange
that it's a really cool poster as well
it's lovely it's so cool yeah
good job by the way mary you just killed
off the
yeah you smashed it yeah it's here
listen you hurt my hands many times
this is so many times poor ethan in his
poor hands my poor hand
i've seen obviously capcom during um e3
announced that they are making resident
evil village dlc
um how if you could have uh lady d dlc
what would you want her to be doing
because personally i just want to see
the adventures of lady d where she's
just like
going about her day and we get to just
like control her or just be around and
see what she does
like oh well yeah doing the most mundane
tasks yeah doing mundane tasks you want
her like washing the dishes not that she
would ever she would order someone else
to do that she would never
she would never um
i'm so fascinated by the
process by which they created the
daughters i think that's really
fascinating and also
i love i love the fact that she's a mom
i've said it before i'll say it again i
love it i love it i love it
i think that says a lot about her and so
i want to know
what brought her to the point where she
decided
she wanted to be a mom to create a
family there must have been something
missing
so that choice i think to become a
mother and to make that step and to
have that responsibility i think is an
interesting one i love you and also
i want to see them being made i think
that'd be cool i love the idea of like a
stealth experience with lady dimitrescu
but she's like 10 foot and you can't
really like
hide her that well but you have to do
your best
kidnapping pine trees yeah exactly
she's carrying the tree yeah
oh the bridge mikey i need uh
i need some guidance
um i think there's a tunnel here
that you can go through if i recall can
you not go up through the door through
the stairs
this door i believe you want to go
through oh the lock
i'll never get adjusted to the yellow
tape meaning shooting
break through them i will always make
that mistake
well i'm sorry i killed you maggie i did
the exact same thing thank you
you'll live to regret it come here
little fish you will
it is so funny i get so many texts from
friends and family of
the sorry i just killed you
love you so much just killed you have
you have you had like
uh have you had friends and family just
be like uh you know this is wild that
you're in this game that i'm
you know obsessed with yeah yeah i had a
couple of friends that
once my name was released they texted me
being like are you kidding me i've been
sipping over lady d for
months and now i find out that it's you
and now i can't send for her anymore
because it's awkward
that's amazing how did you come across
the role at first did you say this
at the beginning of the stream did you
say this was your first mocap role or
sorry like
voice acting role for a game oh yeah
it's a wild story i had
just completed my master's degree in
classical acting from lambda so i was
living in london
and then kind of moved to la in 2019
immediately after i graduated
and then i booked this job a few months
after i moved to l.a
wow how wild is that and i found it i
was an unrepresented actor so i was
doing a lot of
what actors do when they first moved to
la which is scanning these different
casting breakdown service sites where
you can submit yourself for auditions
i happened to see this one it had
all fake information you know what i
mean it was a fake breakdown so they
weren't releasing any information and i
just happened to see it and fit the
specs for it and i thought
might as well apply i've got nothing
better to do
and here we are what a role were the
specs what did they specify they were
looking for
i almost died oh
i don't remember that was so long ago
yeah i think there was a height
requirement which obviously i fit
so it's so rare for me as a tall woman
to find things that
my height is an asset for so i was like
check i'm immediately applying to this
that's super cool you got it without
representation though that
yeah is impressive yeah i think that's
pretty unusual especially for a game of
this
um caliber it really does feel like one
of those moments where
she's just a baby luck meets
preparedness and opportunity because i
had just completed i'm so
i've done training at the wazoo you know
what i mean it was such a natural fit
for me to step into this world because
it pulls so much from
my background my classical training my
training in different
psychological movement philosophies for
acting as well like lauben
and my music background so a lot of the
voice
work that i'm doing for lady d is i'm
thinking about sound very consciously
and that's something i really like to do
so
it really did feel like a natural fit
and then i just happened to
find a piece of luck that led me to that
opportunity
and then i was able to take advantage of
it because i had done all the work
already
well we're glad that that stroke of luck
happened because
a hell of a character to to have in the
uh the video game world now
seriously yeah i can't wait to see her
in smash
yes put lady d in smash let's go
um sadly it looks like we've reached our
time
end of our time with maggie um but
we want to thank you for coming on super
appreciate and also thank you for
opening up that poster and also you know
thank and congratulate you for doing
such a great job
wonderful job incredible job yeah
i'm more than happy i'm more than happy
to be here with you guys and to offer up
the poster it's such a pleasure to be
here
truly truly an honor um i want to get to
the duke can i stay on until we get to
there yeah
of course he's my favorite character
he's like you can stay over as long as
you want
maggie yeah you can hang out for as long
as you want you stay as long as you want
and i want to see your reaction
would you mary is this is your first
time playing the game so this is my
first playthrough but i've played
through this section before but this is
my first play through the game i haven't
finished the game
um so i i'm playing through it right now
with mike mike and i have played through
every resident evil in the numbered
series plus a couple extras like code
veronica
and we played them all together with
mike as my guide
um and so we are very i don't know how
close we are mike to the
end but um she just she just finished um
the dr morose section last night oh okay
she's going toward like heisenberg and
everything yeah she's got like four
hours total yeah
yeah cool cool um but
because i didn't know the thing that the
duke reveals about the item you just got
from castle demitresque
i didn't know that until i watched this
playthrough i was like
yeah there's so much that we don't know
i mean probably the fans are more of an
expert on this game than the people that
were in it
the actors that were in it hey maggie
would you do me a favor
would you mind like putting on your lady
d voice and threatening chat
and being like you better behave
you better behave in the chat
or else you'll be sliced to ribbons
wow flip that please
everyone clip that i'm going to use that
for the rest of my life mary mike you
can
use that on your resin evil streams and
videos feel free
exactly the slice to ribbons is my
favorite thing that's my go-to now when
i threaten people
we just want to work out the claws we
have people in twitch chat saying but
what if i want to be sliced into ribbons
that's a problem
that's a personal choice you do you
follow your bliss
youtube chat we deserved that we will
behave
we deserve that there's a lot of yes
ma'ams as well in the chat which is
wholesome awesome
could be worse could be a lot worse
lady d in mortal kombat is my dream yeah
that's it yeah some people saying that
too and we're like dead by daylight dlc
yeah oh dead by daylight would be great
yeah that'd be perfect
where are you i hear you eating someone
i have inventory free i'm gonna go back
up for those bullets i have to increase
my inventory i'm so screwed with this
tiny inventory i can't wait to see the
duke
i want to double my inventory mr duke
i love when you catch him sleeping yeah
and he wakes up and he's like
oh my god i thought they
i i thought the item was gone but that's
not resident evil in resident evil they
always let
the items like stay forever
yeah i i don't know about you but like
um that one line he has about you know
where he does the uh
uh the reference to the merchant and
christmas thing that the old friend of
mine says now like
my mind was spinning with this like
resident evil connected merchant law
i was like if there's gotta be more to
this i hope they
lean into that there's a couple lines
i'm looking forward to mary hearing for
the first time especially with
heisenberg i think the one that
everybody here is like wait a minute
i haven't this has a bunch of
implications for resident evil lore
yeah i don't uh i don't
know any of the secrets at the end and
i'm not going to look at chat because i
can't
trust you guys but they've been told to
behave so and they've all
uh they've all complied so they won't be
that's right
yeah i've better do it i found a way to
not get spoilers so far and my goal is
to keep it that way but i'm so excited
because this game is
an absolute joy to play it's got
incredible action
it's iconic in terms of just having
those traditional resident evil feels
um but it's also got a sense of humor to
it it's
it's cheeky and entertaining it's got
it's got it all man
it really is the package
is this locked wait so we didn't talk
about this but how great was carol
as the prophecy lady
oh yeah i remember at the table read the
first time she opened her mouth the
whole room went silent and we were all
like
oh my gosh that is cool
like such a great level of spooky but
also with this sort of
terrifying like tinge to it
it's just like really unsettling but in
the best way
i've got a few donations i can read out
while mary makes her way to
the merchant and the duke
he scared me sir go ahead
ten dollars from cali dollars from nawaz
iqbal
uh ten dollars from gila chris l says
huge fan of knievel thank you mary
and mike question for maggie does she
play resident evil or any other games
and that was 25
that's a good question oh i
sadly am not a gamer i never grew up
with a console so
i'm horrible at it i love to watch other
people stream
and play um but i was you know a sci-fi
fantasy
nerd so i was reading a lot of books and
am definitely familiar with all of the
archetypes that you see in games
oh here he is aries
it was all worthless is that so
i assume you've picked up something of
value a piece of my baby not sure if
it's a value
but why
you have your daughter right in your own
hands
what are you saying take a closer look
yeah this was a holy [ __ ] moment this
really is shocking
naturally you gotta the same way that
the magic water heals his hands
this this is impossible this just can't
be
your daughter's essence is still intact
her powers are truly unique
oh who could even do this she can be
saved you know
saved from this are you insane
there's a house with a red chimney on
the western side of the village
go and seek out the man who lives there
and we can continue our conversation
quit holding out and get to the damn
point
you don't have to trust my words
but do you have any better options
the duke move around so quickly how did
he get from castle dummy trask
to this an underground tunnel
underground network
then maybe that's a dlc i want to see
the duke's underground network
yeah it's a metroid it's a metroidvania
style game
that's so that's so terrifying and it's
such a cool
concept that they added to this game
just collecting
pieces of my kid body parts yeah
i've got a few more donations i want to
quickly read off um info
25 angelique another 15
um ali gave uh twenty dollars and said
sending so much love to you amazing
people
and this much uh needed charity um
thanks for bringing on maggie um
and using the platform it's a shout out
away a true icon um
ten dollars from dawn uh alessandro gave
twenty dollars
and said let's give uh my guy ethan
winters a hand for being dad of the year
casaro one two three ten dollars they're
donating because we love helping people
and not because maggie owns my soul
anyways love from their blood bags
oh blood bags blood bags uh vincent
fifty dollars
uh yeah i think that's everyone
uh ethan gave ten dollars and said
maggie deserves best role of the year at
the game awards
she does ethan
i hate that man and then finally
sarah inez besombe gave
ten dollars and saki
20 good luck with the stream thank you
so much everyone before i see you
and remember if you want to be in with a
chance of winning the poster
the signed resident evil village cast
posted that maggie has very kindly
provided
uh go to my tweet my twitter username is
right there it's pinned
uh reply with screenshot of your
donation with all your
identifying bits like covered and uh we
will put it into a random generator and
pick a winner
and while you're there i've got my
spreadsheet is on the glow
while you're there you can see mike
muharry's tweet uh twitter username
there as well just take a really up
close picture of your face and tweet
that at him
um let's see if we can get him loads of
pictures of your faces please
before i sell it this is this is lady
dee's
uh this is what you get for killing you
it's beautiful i saw someone just tagged
me in something where they
have sculpted that oh wow
you're amazing i would keep this in mind
i would love that i would so love that
look how beautiful that is
very big and i've seen fan art of lady d
as the figure
the crystal figure that's beautiful too
oh
that is lovely so much talent you guys
truly truly cool let's sell her let's
get rid of her
well give me all your money this is
gonna
buy that inventory
[Laughter]
this is real lovely buy it from me
priceless anyway gun
get rid of it
[Laughter]
they do do that a lot in this game i'm
gonna save
yeah thank you duke maggie you're of
course welcome to hang out uh
anytime you want but if you do want to
dip out just let us know and we'll uh
get to work on now is the time that i
must do it
unfortunately okay thank you again so
much thank you so much for having me on
this is so much fun
you guys are awesome is there anything
you want to plug before you head out
um uh you can follow me on
social media twitter and instagram at
maggie the bard
and then um i'm also selling signed
autograph cop
prince and whatnot on streamily you can
find that at www.streamley.com
maggie robertson and we also have some
trio house dummy trust
prints that we're selling as well which
are super cool and definitely check it
out
awesome awesome thank you so much for
your time
take care have a good day thanks guys
now you got to make some sausage while
we watch
it so we're still mary's and mike's
still going to be streaming the game
we'll be here having fun and obviously
if you are donating still
we're gonna leave that competition open
until for another hour or so like
give us maybe five minutes at the end of
the stream to you know pick the
the winner um donate tinyurl.com
playful 2021 to win a signed copy
uh a signed picture of the cast of
resident evil village
uh that maggie signed um and a bunch of
the other
famous faces from the game and then come
and tweet at me
uh lucy james games my pinned tweet if
you reply to that with a screenshot of
your donation
uh but obviously don't dox yourself
cover your
identifying information and we're gonna
randomly select a winner
at the end of the stream and then we
will get that sent to you
so very exciting and a bunch of people
have been donating and putting
uh tweeting at me so keep them coming
ten dollars or more to enter ten dollars
or more
we've crossed the nine thousand dollar
mark yeah
we did it yeah and we've got a few more
donations we got 20
from the great polio who says kanini
forever this is an amazing course thank
you for doing this
and then stay alive jen you gave fifty
dollars hey
we love jen jen's a regular um thank you
guys so much for
all of your kanini love and all your
lady d love and
this is all going to a good cause so
good good stuff
lady d love
i just heard you say d love d love
uh we had um susie spearhunter in the
chat on youtube earlier
oh hi susie hey susie
is a legend just check out her review of
um
village which was real good yeah um
some incredible resident evil content
all right is that done let me know if it
looks stupid if other than that i'm
going to keep going
that looks perfect amazing it looks
great
oh bird
i'm gonna honestly though mike without
spoiling anything what would you want
the dlc for village to be no spoiling
and and mary as well i guess but um
without without mentioning any spoilers
um i'd like to see the
the the family dynamics before this game
between heisenberg and moreau and
beneviento and lady d
how they're interacting before you first
see them in that like rogues gallery
scene before you
run from heisenberg um
i'd also i wouldn't mind some
like a prequel dlc playing as like chris
and the dudes that you see
uh beating you up like mary that you saw
them kind of ambush you last night
before you fought moreau yes
i'd like to see what they were up to
like investigating this before you got
here
or before they came and killed mia or
yeah
before chris shot mia like 300 times
yeah
an unnecessary amount of times so many
times like he enjoyed it on some level
yeah he shot her like six times and then
when she was on the ground he shot her
another six
just to just a double down just to like
make sure chris is like by doing that
chris has just outed himself as like a
bad
uh agent like bad operative because that
is like incredibly wasteful of
ammunition
mary though he's just uh praying to the
altar of lady
yeah i for one welcome our lady d
overlord
i pray to the altar of lady d every
night you know what i mean
hold on god
you guys invited me on yeah at least i
mean like this is
this is this is why we invited you this
is what we miss
this is what we miss having uh
lady ds nuts oh there it is
there it is i was waiting for it i knew
it was coming
oh uh thank you matt hawking with the
ten dollars with the
with the comment it's over nine thousand
hey
look like um a person with glasses doing
this
when's the last time we were all on like
a on camera together were we ever all
four of us
i don't think so
i was not with lucy i was out with timur
i was out with mary separately
um it's been a while it has been i mean
mary i'm not sure if you and i ever did
anything
i'm trying to think in the same room
i've been avoiding things for lucy for
years
i think i like i've definitely been in
videos with you where like
i've shot in the uk and you've shot in
the u.s and it's been spliced together
there must have been like an e3 or
something where we did
so you know a lot of e3's i was behind
the scenes
typically producing the show i think
it's really possible though but i
remember distinctly when you came to
trailer
for like the first time we got really
drunk at a bar
and i took a photo of you in the subway
system and i said
welcome to america now get in this
shitty subway system
you did uh so i remember like vividly
when you first came here being really
excited but it was from i think it was
like right around
my like either departure of the city or
something because i was
moving to um
i was moving to portland at the time
it was september 2018 it probably would
have been
so yeah right about then but i do
remember um
e3 2019 mike you mary and i did the
trailer rating thing with like greg and
oh yeah easy allies and stuff right um
yeah
was that 2018
that would have been 2018 yeah it was my
last e3 i did with you folks
we should do it more i was in the crowd
for that one oh [ __ ]
um now yeah now that i uh
i don't know if we like talked about
what we do but i work at twitch now
publicly you guys know what i do um we
can
easily stream and hang out and
play some games i like to play dead by
daylight a lot i don't know if you guys
ever played that it's very fun
oh i have it is a lot of fun stupid it's
been supporting that a lot
since its initial release i did silent
hill dlc with pyramid head
what was the most recent one they just
released it was uh didn't vote like
claire and and yeah they did they're in
their
survivors yeah pyramid head is in there
sorry they always scare me
i tried to guard that and i didn't that
wasn't my best
thanks for the recap
didn't go well for me
oh he's dead uh it's like such sergey 87
in the chat says assassin's creed
wine tasting was the best hey yeah
god that was such a like that was a
funny video ubisoft
do you mind if we send you a crate of
wine
i heard somebody across the room asking
like yes please take it
that was that was one of my favorite
videos i've ever made
um purely because it was just like
you suggested it and i was like yeah i
haven't got much going on let's do it
and then you turned you just sat next to
me just went
you know i took a wine course in college
and then you just started throwing out
stuff like tannic
and legs and i was like i don't know
what this means this is just definitely
wine for me
do that video i remember thinking he
could be making all of this up and no
one would be able to
that's the thing about sommeliers most
of them you could just you could just
say
legs and tannins and everyone goes this
guy knows wine and he's like
you can tell that it's a a red wine by
the color
you could tell it's a tempranillo
because of the way it is
yeah that was i think i've undersold how
much i'm in i like
re like obvious wine enthusiasts
uh in my free time but yeah i probably
did make a lot of [ __ ] up
i mean you're you're a gin boy now
aren't you chin boy
i still prefer wine but yeah i've been
trying a lot of gin like i knew it was
coming and it still scared me
oh yeah that guy i had um a really awful
bread mixy fat moment with um because of
a quarantine i became very
into gin and tonics and i was telling um
loose o'brien from ign that uh i was
doing that and she went
you know tonic's like really bad for you
right i was like what
and she went yeah yeah tonic has like
it's worse for you i think she said than
like
coke or something and i was like oh god
i got more sugar i think yeah yeah it's
really
really sugary and i had no idea and then
i switched to a light tonic
and it's just not the same so i've
actually gone to wine which i know is
still sugary as hell
needs money uh yeah you're still getting
mo a lot of times you're getting a
natural sugar too much sugar
i'll just switch to wine regen i stick
to seltzer because it
it doesn't mask the gin taste as much
i'm trying your gin but yeah
i got like ginger i just signed up for
uh oh my god oh wow
who opened that gate
ethan can swap weapons inhumanly fast he
could do a lot of things inhumanly
especially you could see like three
hands if you pause the frame yeah yeah
you can
like his the way he puts the guns and
pulls the guns out from
it doesn't make any sense it's like
they're all just dangling from a belt
and he just keeps bringing them up i'm
sorry he's literally just got his
daughter's head in a jar
yeah yeah you guys are like well he's
where he's going
his weapon is too quickly no holster on
earth can carry that many guns
oh twofer there's a bit i was trying to
do when
mary first found the flask and he looked
at it says rosemary on it
i tried to do a bit where it's like now
he just needs thyme and
parsley stop it didn't work
sprinkle it on a salad yeah
with jokes mike's rosemary throws a
bunch of spaghetti to a wall and sees
what sticks
he's just constantly slinging jokes left
and right hoping for a couple winners
slinging slinging yeah yeah just
pedaling bits just out here like [ __ ]
babe ruth didn't get all those home runs
by not swinging
just felt wrong not to swing i thought
wrong not to swing
i was born to swing tell merrell to
swing away
i love making fun of that movie but i
also [ __ ] love that movie it's really
good
it's actually a good movie so is the
village i'll stand by this
oh i'm really enjoying the um the
village
yeah what was the uh nick cage movie
that we watched
with um uh with jake before he
he uh left after the wicker man probably
right that's what we watch yeah
oh my god that movie is i've never seen
it until we watched it and i was like
what is going on have you seen the
original or no
with the christopher no i've not seen
the original that one's actually good
good
um the nicholas cage version is like so
bad it's good
yeah they're not the bees section yeah
like
because that's the extended one right
i've seen it many times but that was the
extended version of and it was
way worse than i could have ever
imagined but also amazing
um so i'm double checking the um
the spreadsheet so if i'm liking your
tweet that means you're on the
spreadsheet
liking your tweet you're on the
spreadsheet
if you don't have a spreadsheet you
ain't coming in
[ __ ] it jeff bakalar just tweeted a
photo at me there's a screenshot of me
in my lower third that says mikey mufasa
i almost introduced you as um mma
aficionado
is married already done that and the
chris chris waters tweeted me a
very close-up photo of his eyeball
i love it tomorrow's request there's a
yes there's an
old ins go ahead no go for it
there's an old inside joke that mike and
i would always play
on each other where um mike would
change my lower third when we streamed
resident knievel on gamespot
every episode he would typically change
it um what was your favorite one mike
i liked lipton gilgamesh and oh yeah
the weirdest one was probably snorlax
charity drive and there was no context
just weird things because i was at the
end of the day and i was exhausted and
then i would just
stream of conscious like be speaking and
writing tongues i didn't know what i was
saying it was out of my hands by that
point in the day
i got a few more donations we got a ten
dollar from ruby angel
hey everybody from kylie who says stay
hydrated
mike stay hydrated dehydrated stay
hydrated i got iced coffee which doesn't
help but i'm gonna
do it anyway and then anes gave
10 and said thank you for helping this
course let's make a difference much love
to you all thank you
i'm trying to poorly get back
to the area with the goat heads
this bit is confusing it took me ages to
figure out where i was supposed to you
have to like climb onto roofs and stuff
oh to get to red red chimney yeah
i like got confused i'm silly because i
was there but then i left to try and get
more ammo and now i realize that
i've gotten lost i think i want to go
actually don't even know where i want to
go
um also if anyone's like why aren't you
killing the animals it's because i
uh would rather spend this time killing
like horrible enemies for you nobody
wants to watch me stab a pig for
20 minutes i felt like such an idiot
because i obviously didn't want to use
ammo
on any of the animals so i just crouch
and then go
trying to stab him psychotic behavior
from lucy there
just stabbing every animal chasing
chickens around the village
i don't like i was telling mike this i
don't like the stabbing of the animals
as a key
thing to do i just don't enjoy
i just don't enjoy it uh but i'll do it
because i want that
stuff yeah especially the bigger animals
like doesn't feel good because they can
look at you i'm like
there is uh a um
what's it called
armored up ahead yeah big lad yeah
i remember i like kite him all the way
back
i'm gonna throw some of these pipe bombs
at his stupid ass wait
that's not him he deserved
now there's a it there's a couple normal
enemies as well first you guys are just
normies
bye oh
oh
okay we're almost there we're almost
there this spreadsheet
i'm very proud of it lucy loves the
spreadsheet she does
where is he um oh there he is
so yeah
i hate this guy okay the um
the almond left oh that guy yeah that's
like me
in a zombie apocalypse though just like
getting he looks like he's got
um just like pans on him yeah that's
what i would do
it was like the it was like the
quarterback on the football team
but he's like i just need to recreate my
armor
uh my outfit
see how you dealt with him so fast holy
crap
no face at all yeah mike taught me that
mike isn't always helpful but every once
in a while he gives me a real
good one and that one was just straight
up get rid of his armor and then once he
doesn't have armor on his head then
shoot his face off and that's the secret
so yeah i tried to fight him with a
knife once and it
ended very very poorly like i it was
like a genuine 10 minute back and forth
you can't knife a lot of the enemies in
this game can you like unlike uh
like the traditional right all knife run
you did not he's
lying he's a liar i've known mike for so
long and still i get god
he looks away when he lies his life is
like this you know he'll be like
[Laughter]
yeah i i'm like uh i'm the voice actor
for heisenberg
i wanna play poker with mike and see if
we can
see all his tells cause he's just got
this [ __ ] eating grin
every time i get i get two aces i'll not
be able to cover it up
yeah you'll be you'll do a tom cruise
like jump up and down again it'll just
be it'll just be like
my face when i like get a good hand is
like the face of people trying not to
laugh and documental and just like
just god i haven't worked documental for
a while
i changed all of it i was talking to
tamora and mary about it i finished
season four the other day i think i'm
the person mary who told you about it
uh joshua i'm trying to figure out who
joe screbel's told me so i yeah i
i gave i bestowed it upon peter and then
i saw it very slowly spreading
to different people so i'm one i'd love
to know where everyone got it from
i don't know i think dan heard about it
through like the panning the stream
community
that's funny i should ask josh how he
found it because he was we i went to
visit him
in colorado he's driving all around the
united states um
being cool right now and he showed
me it while i like came over to his
house and i was like how this is the
most
insane concept and it's so stupidly
funny
it's so good the ana olympics oh my god
anything jimmy does i just die laughing
like have you guys seen the video of uh
no laugh pie hell
yeah the matsumoto is like
part of the comedy troupe that did like
gaki no tsukai
um which was like very but there's one
which is legendary which is
there's two of them they're sitting on a
chair they're tied to this chair
uh in the middle of a stage and on
either side
there's dudes who are wearing no pants
and they have their ass
their butt cheeks spread and every time
every time one of the contestants gets
something wrong
a platform brings the two butt cheeks or
the two people who have their asses out
closer to the people tied to the chair
so the person who gets the most
questions wrong
ends with their face buried in someone's
bomb
that is the kind of nonsense that they
did in that show
and i was just like there's one which is
amazing which they like
they had like uh they're on top of like
a ski mountain like a mountain where
skiing is happening and they had a
portal party there
but they didn't tell anyone that the
porta potty was on wheels
and they'd wait for like people to go in
there and then just
take the brakes off and they'll just be
this poor party traveling down a
mountain
with people freaking out and it was just
like amazing
but yeah gaki no tsuka is is one of the
funniest shows ever
i regret not buying the dvd because we
saw it when uh
last time we were in japan we went to
like uh
where did we go it was okay multi-story
h m not h m hmv
i found these feathers now tell me how
to fix this like you said you would
settle down i love this [ __ ] i
literally just like just put the
feathers on the key mate
um figure it out easy peasy
i've got this key and i've got this
metal bit that looks like it would fit
inside a key what do i do
what do i do like you can reattach a
hand
you can't fix a key
we have another hour and i wonder if we
can get
to the other
part mike with the basement
second
if you're not you don't have to worry
about ammo for that section because
there's no gun so you could sprint
straight through then
the um the forest i just think it would
be a funny
not funny i think it'll be a great way
to a great way to
end it if we can get there yeah that
would be cool
um zarship says there's a trophy for an
all knife run
in re8 is that true there it is that's
yeah
mad uh
mike can you do your impression of uh
the feet of saying daddy
oh yeah yeah sure
ready daddy i don't like it in here
ali daddy please get me out of this
flask
oh my god daddy where's my body with my
legs daddy
where my legs and feet and body baby
please get me out of this flask
see i was i was this is way better than
what i asked for because i was going for
the uh
the impression of the the boss in that
next area
that you were doing on fire escape
podcast because that was like
that crippled me with laughter wait a
minute what impressions way better
you were doing you're doing an
impression of uh oh what do you call it
uh
the i mean we're gonna do spoilers here
right the fetus that changes
it chases you around in the uh oh gotcha
the oh that's venus i thought you might
have rose
i was that ma that was incredible but
also just made me like
curl up inside a little bit a fetus is
more like
be my daddy ethan please be my daddy
let me eat you ethan that's almost like
a
thought you were spoiling something and
i ripped my cookie monster combo
you've seen all of everything we're
talking about no no no
i when you said that part i liked i just
instinctively ripped off my headphones
[Music]
no i i knew i know you've played that
bit because i listened to it on fire
escape so i wouldn't have gone anything
anywhere after it dude
my face was so you you played that bit
with the the bit
yeah the big scary bit i've done the
basement when i was yeah
yeah yeah so when i was playing that um
i texted kurt curtin divina
gamespot host um i'm
hiding under the bed and may never come
out because i was talking to chris
morris
gamespot editor and i said like i was
telling him like i was really enjoying
this bit
and it was a bit that had really scared
me the most obviously in the level there
is
a bed that you can hide under so i just
texted that to curt with no context
forgetting that like two months prior i
had changed my phone number and he did
not have that
so he was just like oh my god
it's like someone is in my house hiding
in my bed and he showed it to his
girlfriend
the context is they had just moved into
a new apartment
yep and the fact is they weren't in they
were at the supermarket or something and
he showed it to juliana and apparently
julian just broke out in a cold sweat
and then i started saying something
about fetus and then i just got this
like dot dot
who is this and i was like i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
everyone leaves me uh we've got a few
more donations i can quickly read david
hawk gave 20
and said love to mary and mike for five
years of knievel goodness
david's david's done a lot of awesome
like um promo art for knievel yeah
he's done i don't know if you guys have
seen it he's he did the season
oh yeah season around he did the that
like blue one where it's
for dark dead space it's got isaac kind
of diving backwards shooting it's really
good
he's done a lot of cool stuff he also
just got a job uh
oh i don't want to butcher this let me
let me double check he got a job
and we're very good shout out to david
hart um
seek alice uh gave ten dollars and said
you guys are amazing keep up the good
word
and then kotonata gave ten dollars
thank you for the donation so far yeah
thank you and if you want to be in with
a chance of winning the
signed resident evil village cast poster
provided to us by lady d
herself uh maggie robertson who was on
the stream earlier
head over to my twitter it's right here
uh reply to my pinned tweet
um that you have donated share
your um your tiltify receipt but block
out your identifying information
i've got a magnificent spreadsheet where
i'm keeping track of everyone if i've
liked your tweet that means you're on
the spreadsheet if i haven't liked your
tweet and you have sent it to me
ping me just send it again just say bump
um and i'll get you on there and then
we're gonna use a random number
generator at the end of the stream
to find a winner ten dollars or more if
you donate ten dollars or more to enter
the
giveaway
david that's sony music now oh but yeah
he's done a lot of cool
promo art this part is just so weird and
so pretty gets quiet and
you're looking for ammo and there's no
ammo and that's disconcerting in its own
way
hey dylan hi my amazing co-worker dylan
is in chat
we love dylan hey oh i've met dylan
dylan's great dylan is lovely
oh someone's clipped out mike's fetus
impression
daddy all right
trying to get to baby
how soon thank you for that i think it's
upstairs i think you can do it we've got
like 50 minutes left i think you can
definitely do it
yeah you may miss well uh i don't think
you could do it
[Music]
not mike he's a [ __ ] absolute villain
i just wanna bring you down to earth
thanks donate to prove mike wrong
oh god what was i doing there's like a
thing i need but i forget where it is
is it in the kitchen uh
i'll find it i'll figure this [ __ ] out
i really like this area of the game damn
it i like the basement i think the
this boss fight is not my favorite
there we go glorified hide and seek game
i want this house though i like this
house
what happens you are gross i
lucy did you have dolls growing up no
i shouldn't gender it did you all have a
doll growing up i did not i had a
huge collection of dolls
[Music]
some say he still does yeah i still do
yeah
i model all the dolls no never mind
that's way too weird yes
yeah himself
and sometimes chad'll be like no say it
and he'll be like if i
catch myself it means i should not say
it
yeah i am getting better at it friend
who had like a bunch of dolls and i
remember going to a sleepover at her
house
and she had them all arranged like
staring
at the bed and i did not care for that
well we know actually i shouldn't say
oh
yes someone that we know that collects a
very specific kind of doll and it is the
ugliest doll
i don't like him i don't like that yeah
i got a doll as a gift when i was
younger and i remember just being like
i don't want it but it was made out of
like a nice porcelain and my parents
were like this is really expensive you
have to keep it and i was like i don't
[ __ ]
want it i think i i know this is
probably something that has
been discussed plenty of times but i've
always been incredibly freaked out by
the idea that
when you know young girls are growing up
they are given a toy which is a young
baby
oh yeah it's a baby for you to play with
there's a lot i find that
incredibly unnerving like that that's
messed up man
rip off her arm and stuff
i i had a huge i had a lot of action
figures when i was younger
i didn't collect them i actually like
olum
built like sets for them
and combined with my lego but i had a
lot of gi joes we had the coveted gi joe
collection in my neighborhood
the coveted gi joe collection see i
wanted a gm
people came from blocks away to see it
i know growing up in london you gotta
you know gi joes were big
what are they what i don't know i wasn't
even funny just pretending i grew up in
london
one of my favorite things was like it
was almost surreal thing still
uh is actually just remembering seeing
you in london
it was like a weird weird like collision
of worlds
yeah that was weird when you came into
the office and i was like yeah why are
you did i not tell you i was coming
thank you because i didn't i think you
did it was just it was just the fact
that you were there because it was like
oh look it's mike but he's
using the london underground this is
weird oh yeah
and everybody convinced me there were
tunnel snakes oh yeah the snakes in the
tunnel
yeah i was there for the week before i
was working from there for a week
i took a few days off as well but that
was before we all flew to gamescom
yeah i just remember the squash story
what squash story well you didn't water
the uh
the squash you drank it
well that was before because we also had
an american um
hr lady for a while yeah and
uh she did that repeatedly so hr had to
put up a sign that said dilute before
drinking
yeah yeah
hmm for squash i forgot what is it i
remember drinking i remember that now
but i've kind of forgotten
yeah tang or whatever but like if you
you put a small amount in and dilute it
but you were
filling up glasses of it and just being
like this is intense is it so strong
oh i love it it's waking me up um
i don't know that our equivalently like
minute like
oh yeah it's cordial
um
i was just amazed by yeah by your
bathroom stalls that go all the way
to the floor and yes and no one can see
you pee
like every and like every time i came to
the states and
use one of your toilets just like a gap
between the door
and the framework of the these souls
like yeah you know
one can like put their face through to
look at what you're doing
as a that is too much if i can make eye
contact with someone
that's the only way i can pee now you
have to make an icon
like it yeah i need something who's
being potty trained
i i pay a neighbor to to watch me with
binoculars otherwise i can't pee
mike's mike's a little freak he needs to
always know that someone is looking at
him while he's
unloading uh yeah let's just say i can't
do a lot of things without someone
watching me
yeah that's why he started screaming
i haven't streamed a long time i stopped
it's true yeah
i mean i just joined mary and dan every
once in a while
wait that's not right i started this dan
started this bit
yeah and i hate charity on fire escape
because i can't
because i can't find it to go up to his
house in connecticut to do charity
streams with him convinced
he's dirty when someone tweeted like
when we tweeted about
you coming on someone replied and said
this is a surprise considering how much
mike hates cherry
there's certain bits that i'm not a fan
of but
i don't know they happen tweezers that's
for the body
all right we're getting it done i'm
gonna get there there's something
there's something that you
dan was saying that he was gonna show
you when you were down next
i can't remember what it was but it blew
my mind that you hadn't
experienced it i it's also when when i
it's the same as when i learned that you
hadn't seen terminator 2 for a really
long time
um yeah i was 20 the whole time
i was 21 when i first saw terminator um
i got this what would dan have been
showing me was it warioware maybe
warioware that's the one yeah
that is an extremely mic series i'm
surprised that people say yeah
i don't know i'm in i want to play mario
golf i want to play
i'm looking forward to the warioware and
advanced words i never played advanced
wars and people are surprised at that
because i like
like tactical games yeah i've also
played advanced wars you're going to
love advanced wars
i think because it's one and two coming
out in december right
the revised ones yeah yeah i hate that
this looks like the mannequin i have in
my apartment shut the [ __ ] up
i use that same bed on table didn't i
i'm recycling bits yeah you're just
reusing bits now
we guys wait wanna hear guys wanna hear
what rosemary would sound like inside
the flask
i mean that was a good one so i would be
all right again wake's got two hours of
material
no i wrote down um gamespot charity bits
and it's just like two things on the
page i ran it i
started she's best friend she likes this
fairy tale
most important thing in the world our
wedding gift proof of ethan's
everlasting love
this is so hard to memorize
i've forgotten what you've said already
favorite thing proof of ethan's the most
important thing in the world to me
uh maybe that
maybe that maybe this
nope maybe that nope
as he pops the banana into his mouth
nope
you did it you know well done i've got a
few more donations
uh we got one from oddpuff for ten
dollars uh jason martin ten dollars
piggy whisperer ryan ten dollars and
then jacqueline demetrescu
mike you have to tell them the story uh
the first time i played through this
i had literally just watched
the ring and i it's an
old it's not that old it's an old film
i think that used to scare like 20 years
yeah it scared the crap out of me when i
was in high school maybe
middle school i can't remember but i was
i was in school and i saw it and i
me and my sisters freaked out um
with how spooky it was [ __ ] all of you
and
i oh my god
i just couldn't let it go the idea of
me bringing that up and watching it
right before this scene
you were you literally just played
yourself you had just opened the door
to go down to the room with the well and
you were absent-mindedly talking about
like oh by the way i just caught up
like i watched the ring and and then i
was like
laughing or quietly laughing and trying
to hide it and then you were talking
about how creepy it was like
the the reveal that she was like died at
the bottom of a well
as before the well came up out of the
shark the shadows here
i almost just said shadows
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god she's coming out of the
shadows
um i need a baby to put in there
all right um i remember the first time i
saw that when it was like it looks like
something can fit in the depression i
was like
that's a tweet that's yeah right there
learning the mandolin can fit in the
depression
crochet which actually i have been doing
quite a lot
it's pronounced crotchet thank you
an old what an overused mannequin can
fit in the depression
if you know what i mean oh my god
i would love a workshop like that i need
for wooden dolls
i'm sure you can get one i'm going to
find one don't encourage final evolution
like the
gesso don't that's not my final that's
just like midway don't encourage it
i don't even know what mine will be can
i take a final evolution would just be
like hooked up to an iv of wine while
i'm
watching what watching my zombies
just reciting the lines as they come out
of characters mouths
yeah and then like in the distance
someone in a doorway like
just a carer and an estranged family
member
this is all he does now and it's just
you responding
the lines over and over i i i actually
this is a very obscure sunny bit um in
the episode
frank's pretty woman when roxy dies from
smoking too much crack and her heart
pops
she she
they're like they're like what was she
doing and dee goes well
she did crack on the way over here oh
and also all day long i used that like
i used that phrasing the other day
someone's like
i was just extremely tired when i met up
with my girlfriend in the city she's
like
what have you been doing i was like i
don't know i uh
i drank like a coffee in the car on the
way over here and also
the seven before that i just think of
that
oh that d-line all the time stop it
dennis is so angry when he realizes dee
did crack without him
one crack please oh oh one crack rock
please
he's still turning away why is he
sauntering away oh there he is
did i do it you guys do you guys i did
it with record time we have 40 minutes
left now to deal with this baby
you gotta see the baby so i just have
rob
screaming baby
if there's anything something about like
she's watching right football match
scar there is something about the cry of
a
baby that does just cut through me yeah
it'll make you keep your iud in forever
just clinging on no you'll never take me
no thank you
you ready no you're never ready for this
part
follow that velvet rope the velvet rope
the first time i played this i didn't
understand
you know you don't really what you're
following here it's awful but you don't
really
i didn't put it together um no i didn't
either
i did but i spend a lot of time around
umbilical cords so oh my god i
i knew it i knew it i knew
so the first time mary mary got like
barely saw the fetus thing
and then when she saw like the the
briefest movement she turned around ran
so right here
right here she didn't yeah she didn't
see it
really she saw the glistening phlegm
whatever it is
can you hide it around this table
uh i think so let's find out
so i had the same thing with the way
that you get out
i just wasn't looking behind me
so like as it's like bearing down upon
you i was just like
what's going on with this music a bit
intense and it's just like coming at me
from behind and i just like the door off
and i was like oh
it's coming at me uh thank you to conrad
owens for the ten dollars with the
comment
yummy yummy eww
oh where the [ __ ] do i go
um i have another one breaker box is
that it
breaker box key
uh yeah so right here i just didn't look
behind me
relief of a child yeah
oh lord um yeah okay here we go
sorry
i think my my favorite moment from
knievel history is still
the fight against marguerite oh god yeah
oh
the the one that kicks it off on the
landing of the greenhouse stairs
no uh yeah yeah yeah no the the actual
fight when
when you're like i think you say
something like we have to be very
careful with your grenade launcher or
your incendiary grenades
you have to be extremely careful and
then like a noise happens and mary just
like a pro mlg flick just shoots it into
an
empty corner of the room and you're like
yeah and then i just hear nicholas cage
from national treasure being like you
handled that well
wasting the immediate that that made me
laugh
so hard there there's a one the other
one that sticks out is the elevator in
residual four you know the elevator
where you're battling waves that are
coming up in the castle
oh yeah mary was down to like her health
was so low it didn't look like she had
any color in the health bar at all
and she opened her inventory to equip
the flash grenades and i told her i was
like all right
this is your one chance to survive so do
not [ __ ] this up so she's okay okay okay
and then took like six deep breaths
unpaused it and threw the flash grenade
over the edge of the elevator so
it just did nothing it dropped down the
shaft and just hit the ground
a mile below and then she immediately
paused again she's like mike i think i
[ __ ] up
all that is to say if you don't watch uh
knievel you
absolutely should because it is some of
the best
content around it's changed so much too
people yeah someone's saying they
restarted it because they were sick the
other day or
out like on pto i don't know and it's
just
very much me guiding mary like through
every step in the first game
at any time she gets relatively stuck
and then flash forward to
result seven where i'm actively
antagonizing her and trying to get
killed
that's growth baby yeah
[Music]
that's when our friendship really
blossomed what am i doing
uh i actually like forget what i'm doing
oh
lord i knew i was like when does it
hurt me
yeah do the i made mary do the bed
because she saw the cabinet back here
and
you can hide in the cabinet too but that
is a really good view
um oh there's a head down
three more seconds a few more seconds
head start to get out of the room
david hart says about when mary killed
mike on the drawbridge in five
oh that was good that was good anime
betrayal
that was a mistake i think that was
intentional
i was in i remember i forget why i was
in a bad mood that day but i was
i watched if i was actually angry like i
remember i was like oh i'm clearly
actually angry at that
you know this is how i feel most of the
time
isn't mikey going to dub this baby
[Applause]
daddy are you under the bed again i told
you i don't want to play night kwawas
are we playing night kwawa daddy
daddy are you in the kitchen can you
make me some soup
i prefer broccoli cheddar please
i'll be under the bed when you need me
bring me my soup
this kid is adorable i know he's cute
we have we have fun uh it's too dark
it's too dark in this house
uh what do i need i need to put the fuse
in the fuse box nine to get the [ __ ] out
i love how quickly his footsteps sound
like they're moving but he's just not
going that far i'd love to see the
animation baby babies are just like
it's the same as like when shepard runs
in any mass effect game
like the camera swoops in and then
you're like basically walking
yeah oh my god let me the [ __ ]
just roadie running in gears of war yeah
what do i do
oh my god
the same thing happened last time it got
so close that i had to like reset it
kind of
i'll be under the bed bring me my block
away
bring me my buckley shadow
tell him i hate it i'm a fan of this bit
uh we've got i don't know
we've got uh just over half an hour
left on the stream please make sure you
go to tinyurl.com four slash profile
2021
and donate we are raising money for
ablegamers an incredible
charity that combat social isolation
social
isolation you got it and makes gaming
accessible
for people with disabilities you've
probably felt some sense of isolation or
even loneliness over the past year and a
half
during the kind of like lockdown phase
um
but there are some people who feel that
their entire lives and
gaming is the only way that they kind of
ease some of that
and gaming isn't as easy to pick up for
everyone as it might be for you
and ablegamers is a charity that tries
to break down some of those barriers so
when you donate towards ablegamers you
are investing in the future of video
games
so please make sure you give money
is there a trick to know where she might
be like you can hear her
laugh right or something or is it just i
think it's
there's like five spots i think she's
always here first but then i think it
can change the next few times
oh can it yeah when mary did it last
time she
there's that room off of the dining room
where i found her mary never found her
there
8-bit dylan says follow the blood oh
thank you oh dylan's gonna strike what a
guide
right fact check this is this is this
good advice or not
my let go gecko in the chat just says
walk away
i miss broccoli cheddar man now that
you've
achieved your right oh
i had a dream about the melt these tiny
blood marks
i saw it and then i lost the blood marks
so oh there we go
yeah okay well then she's in here
where are you [ __ ] there she is oh
interesting okay
good job thank you hey todd
i mean oh look at that
spot on little oh wow i did not know
that
good tip uh upstairs
that was from piggy whisperer ah i don't
know i thought it was toward the
elevator
i already committed to going in here
risky
and they're all shaking and they're oh
fudge this was
it
because i opened my face toward the
elevator okay okay
like in here that's no that's the front
shoot shoot
shoot i'm running out of time down to
your right hard right
finish here
and that's how you kill a doll
did you ever read goosebumps heck yeah
yes do you remember slappy the dummy
oh yeah it was like that version of
chucky yeah
i found that lad terrifying i'm glad
they put like a doll
archetype into this game as an homage to
that genre of spooks
yeah it's very funny they go from
like general fear of being
chased maybe bugs to fear of dolls
to fear of water like deep water and
then it's just
metal man and factories
legs fear of industry
yeah jrr tolkien story
man it's crazy the first time i played
through this it took a couple hours but
when you
know a little bit of where to go um you
can kind of burn through it
but it's really yeah i've seen people
finish it in like the whole game in a
couple hours and i'm like
all right all right all right
gdq min maxing that baby
uh baton looking for there you are
okay we got a few more donations we got
ten dollars from peanut who says
spooky and then jackie gave ten dollars
too
thank you remember if you donate 10
or more and you want to be in with a
chance of winning a signed resident evil
village cast poster that was provided to
us by
lady dimitrov uh herself maggie
robertson she was on the stream earlier
uh go over to my twitter reply with
proof of donation
um to my tweet uh obviously block out
your identifying information
i've got a big spreadsheet going on uh
towards the end of the stream we'll put
all of the numbers into a random number
generator pick out a winner
and then we will arrange to get you that
prize
um ten dollars or more tinyurl.com
playful2021
it's on screen that way super worth it
uh dib pointed out that i
did not collect the torso which would be
really stupid
um this isn't my actual i mean it is an
actual playthrough but it's not
the playthrough i'm going to continue so
i'm going to
burn this play through when we're done
so it's okay oh
oh like missing the piece of heart from
ocarina boss
gabe uh our very own gabe said slappy
the dummy is one of the goosebumps is in
one of the goosebumps movies with jack
black
oops i've not seen that goosebumps movie
i haven't either oh you're right there
no i'm sad about not seeing the
ghostbusters
movie get on the ground
is this a body do you come alive i knew
it
[ __ ] you know rl in rl stein stands for
ronaldo
[Laughter]
ronaldo
and where does he get them from yeah
where does he get these
mary is an easy crowd when she's
distracted by gameplay
that's such a good fact you know
yeah funny drink bring it to the next
dinner party didn't normal stein like
have an award
that like he made and then he just gave
it to himself
probably that's hilarious he was also
known as jovio bobstein
if you go to his wikipedia page i
guarantee you'll find it is
they called him jovial bob stein
oh i see what you're saying yeah um
yeah in december he tweeted i am so
honored to have won the rl stein
creative writing award
for the third year in a row the award is
given annually to an author named ariel
[Laughter]
what a champion look
love yourself as much as rl stein loves
himself
he's been referred to as the stephen
king of children's literature
i don't know why i find that phrase
funny even king could be the stephen
king of children's literature
if parents just if you go to
what their kids are reading if you go to
rl stan's wikipedia page there's two
pictures of him
and in both pictures he looks like he's
high as a kite
yeah he does i'm going i'm going
he looks like he is smashed
uh thank you guys for subscribing to rl
stein facts
yeah every 10 donation will tell you
another absolutely true
rl stein wait he has a book
called um jerks in training he has a
series
jackson training loses in space and
bozo's on patrol
oh mary did you know he was born in
columbus ohio
and he grew up in bexley i
think i knew this because uh
one of our in cincinnati we have a
roller coaster named after the beast
which is a r.l stein book oh um
so it's uh what's it called uh king
oh my god i feel like an idiot uh it has
kings island that's the we have a lot of
theme parks in ohio by the way we have
more theme parks than any other state in
america possibly
anywhere uh and
rl stein was kind of coveted and he
wrote the beast and the son of the beast
and we have two roller coasters
both named after him and the son of the
beast is the only wooden roller coaster
that has a loop
arl stein oh my goodness of a loop
absolutely not
yeah i think they should be in place you
said that on fire
that's crazy i think they shut it down
there's a place in um in the uk called
light
is it like water valley where i went for
my birthday one year
my 19th birthday and
we were there for one day four rides
broke in one day and one of them was the
wooden roller coaster so like in
in the uk we have the longest wooden
roller coaster it doesn't have a loop
but people um got stuck on it as it was
just about to go up the final big
descent
and they were there for like an hour and
it was i just remember us being like
oh let's just go home that sounds
this reminds me it's stressful this
reminds me
what mary's story kind of reminds me of
um when i was like
walking through my area of london a
little while back
and like i've always just walked through
the station and there's just these
massive massive uh like murals of
uh scenes from alfred hitchcock movies
and it took me literally
years to realize that it's because
alfred hitchcock is born in the area
that i live in the uk
it took me forever and i was like oh
that now everything makes sense for the
longest time i was like why is this
place obsessed with hitchcock
why do i live on the bird street yeah
um dylan i'm proud of you
they have like the vertigo thing which
the spiral background which when she's
falling
i believe so yeah well they've
i'm not that like uh familiar with a
bunch of
like uh hitchcock movies i know the
basic ones you know
um so there's some stuff that are like
really really cool and weird looking
ones
where's the [ __ ] ball for this
is it past the bridge uh
no it's where are you uh
this house and there's a labyrinth
puzzle so it has a ball and
uh i don't think i can get to here yet
because this is uh there's like garden
stuff here
so i want to say so i know where it is
go left go left to left
go down yes it's through the other
midsummer tunnel thing to your left got
it thank you
around here on the ground i missed it
last time we got 10
we got 10 donation from lee grades who
says thank you for another
fun stream this is such a worthy cause i
wish i could give more
that's plenty lee thank you so much yeah
thank you you are in
you're in the in the draw yeah hinapuf
gave 20
and left the heart emoji for you ah
i also think um any donation at all
any money that you have with your
hard-earned money
is so greatly appreciated i don't it
does not matter if it is a dollar
it's just a wonderful gesture so thank
you to everyone
yeah we had we had steve swann from
ablegamers on yesterday and
you know he made it clear that he
believes that
a single dollar improves the life of
someone
who needs it through ablegamers so don't
feel like
you need to donate massive amounts of
money just a single dollar is enough
yeah and if you like even if you can't
donate like that's totally fine if you
share the stream uh maybe it'll
come across like maybe someone who can
donate will come across it and we'll
give some money so like there's multiple
ways of how to help
share the stream share like the good
words about ablegamers like
uh i think it's ablegames.org it's their
website
um multiple ways
yes we had steve on um
an episode of speed run last year is one
of my favorite episodes
yeah he's great we played marbles with
him yesterday so i
i'd never seen this before but like you
integrate with
the twitch chat and then you hit like
you
type in exclamation mark play and then
your marble like your
your twitch name comes from oh my god i
can't speak
comes above a marble and then you erase
them
and then it's like all integrated super
cool
that's probably one of my favorite
streams that we've done why do you run
at me it's just outrageous that when
they stumble they stumble towards you
they're always focused on the objective
they're so dedicated
uh i hear you i hear your anger
i do not see you there you are
son like a therapist right now i hear
you i hear what you're saying your anger
we're just about out of time however
only 500 i only accept cash
or smooches
[Music]
has been really difficult for mike's
therapist lately
especially because we only have to meet
it we can only meet at mcdonald's
[Music]
when i say mcdonald's i mean
when i say mcdonald's i mean inside the
dumpster behind mcdonald's
oh i think you're going to say inside
the playpen oh that'd be awesome
her name is lucy and she
she does it for mental health she's got
the little sign up and everything
not this lucy it's a different lucy
but i have to protect your honor lucy to
make sure it's clear
that you don't me you don't meet people
in a mcdonald's playground
and give them mental health help in
exchange for smooches
it's just not something that she does
not in the last 20 years or so now
but that was another time
it was different find some quality
ingredients and bring them to me
large crystal crystal skull
[Music]
why did you just though indiana jones
yes the worst you were whispering
everything and then
you went crystal skull
large crystal crystal skull
girl uh lance spence asks how are y'all
doing this stream right now
it's not remix it's through discord and
obs
yeah i'm using obs and i use
discord to as a window capture and
capture them in
and then audio is the hardest part i use
voice meter potato
and i use that so that when i connect my
discord audio
they are getting my desktop audio and my
voice audio
and i get their audio separately and put
it through obs
that way i don't hear myself which would
be so annoying
i hate hearing myself every time i see
the play for all logo the
acronym one above mary i just think it's
persona 4 arena
yeah andrew golf said the same thing and
he was livid about it
yeah that it wasn't just a two-week
person why aren't you playing persona 4
arena well i will get to it
i don't think i've actually played arena
i played dancing but i didn't
um i didn't do arena i still have not
played persona 4.
i have it on steam golden um
i played i'm actually like halfway-ish
through shimagami tensei 3
on switch it's good so far
very annoying but i'm enjoying it i'm
just watching my hands
this guy's got so much dexterity there
you go
oh yeah three hands there he is i
started playing metroid fusion again
yesterday
game's good that game is good uh i'm
still trying to finish
persona 5 royal
it's a long game a palace you win where
are you uh i'm in the final i mean
um i don't want to give away names uh in
case
folks are watching haven't played i'm at
the ship palace i'm just right at the
end of it
oh god that palace is
not my favorite i don't i know people
give um
spaceport a lot of [ __ ] but i think the
ship is much worse
um i think i've already been here
uh does this metroid count as a game
that would work [ __ ] evil
i would love to see you play um
especially fusion i that's a great point
uh i love the metroid series and i would
absolutely play it
um with mike we we really enjoyed the
dead space series together
so i think we kind of are open to a new
series to rummage through i don't know
that could be the one because especially
fusion with the stalking element of it
kind of works yeah see i was already
here um
mike i might need your help
um um is it here i want to go gonna go
to
moreau technically
uh i mean i guess like at this point
you're you're not gonna really do much
in more anyway no i got 10 minutes left
where should i spend them
um like i don't want to like redo stuff
i've already done
i forget i wanted to get to the fishy
man but i don't know if i'm gonna get
there in time
it's really hard to like oh before him
there's like a cool wolf
we could do the wolf if i can get there
oh yeah i don't know where he's in the
field
no you can't do that yeah that's after
moreau i just get like really turned
around
um in this i think one of the things oh
i don't know
confusing go up to the the thing that
was previously locked a bit to your left
the mausoleum to your left left left
sorry yeah that
that door right kind of to your left is
open now
oh yeah yeah oh yeah if you pick up that
and then go to the
um yeah that's
uh you actually haven't done that in
your playthrough mirror we need to do
that next time oh
spoilers you get a sneak peek right now
okay yeah it's just another like hidden
mini boss
wait what do you want to send me the
spreadsheet yes
start loading names in well no you just
um
just put a number generator between 1
and 50.
oh you can do it you can do it in the
spreadsheet no
no just go google random number
generator all right okay
and then put in where is it go back to
where you came toward house beneviento
oh okay yeah it was that tombstone while
the dolls on it
yeah oh cause i have this claudia
headstone
yeah you got it at the end of the last
episode but
this is cool it's cool doing stuff
because you you've
you fought the um the where the prime
werewolf in the field though with all
the spears in him
oh yeah that thing was so difficult to
kill
oh my god people pointed out that it
only takes like two or three magnum
rounds but we always save those for the
end
never use your magnum round not until
the final boss never knievel save them
for the end when you can look at them
because everything's over but you've
still got your magnum rounds that's
right yeah and you can kiss them
yeah just kiss them each individually
okay we've got maybe five minutes left
on the giveaway so if you are arming an
arring uh and you but you you really
want to be in with a chance of winning a
signed resident evil village
cast poster um
donate tinyurl.com playful2021
take screenshot of your donation
confirmation and tweet it to me
it's my pinned tweet and then
this is for ten dollars or more um and
then we'll put it in
the giveaway and you might be in with a
chance of winning so i'll put like a
five minute cap on that
but if you have different amount that
you want like if you want to give one
dollar or five
please keep those rolling in every
little helps
how soon is very kindly put a link to
the tweet in the chat thank you
thank you thank you um where do i put
this headstone
i actually don't know i keep going just
follow the path along pretty much
right in front of
didn't think i went through the bridge
again
this bit was yeah this was
this was a lot yeah you'll be great
you'll do
you'll do great i've like literally
don't know what you're talking about and
i
didn't buy any amp you had practice for
or like
look for anything i've done yeah you'll
die no effort
okay wait no no no no straight keep
going straight
oh no too straight two straight left
all right way behind you oh
black phillip easy
the scariest part of the witch um
ignore him okay just keep going toward
house beneviento okay
i just follow the goat i guess i don't
know
out of my way
uh keep go right yeah that way follow
this dirt path i'm so lost
left stupid there you go keep following
us yeah they never finish their people
in these games they start to eat them
but they only ate the legs they can't
yeah right here put it on this little
[Music]
oh my god he just cleaved you in half
there it is like vertically like
you are two hot dogs now i'm okay i'm
okay i'm okay i'm okay i'll just put
some
hot dogs with three hands i'm gonna put
this i thought they
i thought he jumped down after you put
the thing down i did as well
as well i just gotta put a little bit of
sauce on my body i'll be all right i'll
be all right don't mind me
vinaigrette i actually
don't have the ammo for this battle
he takes a lot use mines and pipe bombs
and [ __ ]
try to kill him you got you got a
grenade you're fine this is just
practice for your actually actions
you need to practice i don't have any
rusted scrap i can't make ammo
that's okay you have a grenade you have
a mine you have a pipe bomb i don't have
wow i've never seen that either he did
not do that to me
they put little dudes in here
those guys they'll drop stuff yeah do
that
i don't have the ammo i don't have the
ammo knife him knife and knife him
step on the mine i don't have the amp
i don't have any i don't have enough
mines yes
oh there you go
god
uh this is what i love crap i'll scrap
that scrap scrap
it's not rusted the gall of them
is a regular scrap
i got you oh great girl
right in the kisser oh i got on my
shoulder
yeah therapist payment mechanism
oh i got him in his tummy oh
little tum tum shot you know you're
doing great mary you're doing great face
oh you're doing all right oh i got him
in this little back hump
okay here we go oh that come
on
[Music]
uh
grenade launcher
i don't have a grenade launcher yeah you
do
you have a grenade launcher and a
explosive grenade give me something
give me that gun powder nice this is
okay you have one oh you oh i see the
problem i get what you're saying oh do
you
understand the problem that i don't have
a gun should i just throw the bullet at
him
[ __ ] use your knife
i don't have any scraps i love that
you're getting scrap yeah but they're
not getting you specifically rusted
why would that be more effective purpose
you got 20 handgun rounds something you
hit him in the face a few times
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
oh my god
oh my god i guess going all over again
i don't have the ammo for this battle oh
my god i'm like
[ __ ] out of ammo
you're doing pretty well survivability
you got some health i thought you would
have got got earlier
due to the lack of ammo yeah seven
handgun rounds left if you kill him with
these i'll be
matt hawking says throw the baby yeah
he's gonna jump
he's gonna jump
god can i eat this round zero says you
got this
this isn't counter strike i get no glory
for this
i get nothing you get bravery
wait until he jumps and then go knife
him
oh my god he's so fast
interesting you don't use the quick turn
i don't use it either because it makes
me sick but
i don't use it because i forget yeah it
makes me sick so i don't use it was it
quit crying you have the upper hand yeah
oh my god he oh there's a there's a lad
there's a lad
knife i'm referring him i don't
i don't even know last
can he hurt them can i get them to see
yeah he can he can he can
here he comes he's gonna jump knock him
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh must have killed him
oh he didn't swing yet i see it takes
him like 10 minutes to swing
some great footwork here though yeah not
wrong not to swing
stop it
nice yeah you got all three get there
get their [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] in the kidneys i thought it
would be like a
like a bloodborne boss if you're like
right in his groin he can't hit you he
just doesn't have the ability
how are you not dead
oh [ __ ] off oh i'm gonna die to these
idiots i'm really hurt i'm very injured
this is it oh
oh he's close i love the game titles uh
lady d chases me around when we're
actually getting chased around by
giant man or with enough
okay one of these guys dropped something
i said
yeah he dropped rusted powder okay
wait handgun ammo probably or shotgun
this is an important decision like
decision shouldn't be
go to your can you go to your weapons
that should you should see the stats of
damage between the new shotgun and the
new handgun i think the new handgun's
higher but i could be wrong
well then you could use the shotgun to
hit multiple enemies and clean up and
get more items quicker
yeah shotguns probably better yeah
three shots
oh wait
little lads
yeah ah i got it
oh wow we got back up
oh it doesn't now come on now i wasted
that
on his knee it's still a hitbox
he'll feel that i'm gonna carry that way
oh um
um oh he's back knife
you just destroyed his pocket
nice nice nice nice
gunpowder
well ads just keep coming if you survive
long enough forever
yeah this game is too polished for them
to just put you in a position that's
impossible
they'll make it virtually impossible but
they will let you
[ __ ] you
this is a david and goliath scenario
here
how much damage do you think i'm doing
to him with this knife
oh
shut up mike can you guys go over your
game spot time
by 20 minutes for me to finish this
[ __ ]
i mean we can hurry up
jump jump you [ __ ]
yeah whiskey samurai points out david
had ammo
all right i say [ __ ] it guys you got it
i think you got it this is a battle of
attrition
i believe i believe in you
i believe in a thing called ammo i need
it really bad
oh [ __ ]
people are enjoying lucy's reactions to
mary's reactions
i just want to win
he's going to jump
yes keep going keep going in that
the guy from futurama rodrigo
rodrigo stabbing robot
i just like stabbed i just just want to
stab him i like the way
it feels what's the matter red you don't
like stabbing
time i've just had a terrifying thought
what's that
i couldn't remember if i'd installed
overwatch for this afternoon stream
oh that's like it's okay it's okay it
says update it doesn't say install it
says update
i think we're okay come on
such an exhausting battle
i mean it is when you've got just a
knife
i'm not prepared for this
you're pulling up a valiant effort this
is impressive there's
gonna be a pyrrhic victory just like
floyd mayweather and jake paul
it's gonna end in a draw
here he comes jump go go
go ham on him right now oh my god that
was close
face i mean like solid i'm getting it
done
it's just uh you know it is a slog
and they're done the merry kiss story
[ __ ] me
i don't want to die with zombie
oh they're cools i'll have you know
he's jumping oh my god it's right on top
here
yeah in the breeze yeah [ __ ] him
up
the game spot in the chat says update
day on the overwatch power net service
no regrets
fantastic effort right we are a few
minutes over
but we're gonna end the stream by
picking the winner of the
poster um which should be
fun uh so how many how many entries do
we have
lucy james 50 lines of entries
so that is 50. which is five like mary's
uh
mary playing mike you're being here too
uh and maggie's poster that is like
five hundred dollars just from the post
to give away and i think we've raised
like over
a grand on this stream oh wow yeah
incredible am i having can you pick a
number between one and ten
seven okay one two
three four five six
seven the winning number is 43.
oh okay 43 that is
um alice
alice
congratulations congratulations you're
in the chat let us know
um you are the proud owner of a resident
evil
village signed poster coming your way
very soon we're gonna reach out to
maggie
and she's gonna we're gonna reach out to
you and maggie um
and we'll get that over to you this is
how our answer is so congratulations
mary mike thank you so much for spending
some of your time hanging out with us
and
uh raising money for an amazing cause
super appreciate it thank you for having
us
it's really fun to do and it's like our
pleasure and
lady d the voice actress maggie what a
talent yeah
what how incredible the way she can just
turn it on as well they jumped out of
the water did you see that
wow somebody animated that someone was
like
it's my friday and i'm doing it
is there anything you guys want to plug
uh before you head off
fire escape we got a podcast uh
western's a fire escape check it out
we release episode fire escape episode
five is up it went up monday
it's every other week so the next
episode number six will be up uh
i don't know two weeks from monday
whatever that is
it's us me it's mary dan reichert and i
and it's us uh
catching up talking about games um
ranting about who knows what every
episode um
so listen to it it's been very fun we
got a lot of great support
for it it's on spotify it's on
apple overcast pocket cast stitcher
wherever you want to go
it is fantastic i do love it there's an
extended section where dan
denies that foods can be aphrodisiacs
which was
quite a quite a moment um revelatory for
him
regulatory but yeah never had a
cheeseburger that gave me a boner
uh thank you everyone for for watching
um we're gonna be back in a few hours
uh uh what time is it 2 p.m upm
pt 5 pm et 5 p.m et
we're going to be playing overwatch with
well it's my game update
if they're game updates we're playing
overwatch we've kind of funnies andy
cortez we've got james willem
uh blaine gibson and joel rubin
we are the best players in the world
we are a terrible overwatch team but
maybe today
we will hit the right moment it will be
a moment i'm excited for it
thank you everyone bye
i was